la russie elle va de nouveau record de
contamination près de 36000 1 500
nouveaux cas hier et 1106 décès en 24
heures ont fait le point justement avec
notre correspondante à moscou maëlys
d'estrées regarder les autorités russes
reste préoccupée par la propagation du
comique 19 cours d'une réunion spéciale
du gouvernement le premier ministre
mirail helmich austin a pointé du doigt
le faible taux de vaccination et
souligné l'importance des tests de
dépistage pour lutter contre la pandémie
chers collègues nous constatons que la
situation liée aux coronavirus est
extrêmement grave dans toutes les
régions de la fédération de russie
le taux d'incidence est très élevé
malheureusement il y actuellement
beaucoup de patients dans un état grave
dans les hôpitaux en particulier ceux
qui ne se sont pas fait vacciner à temps
et les médecins luttent pour sauver leur
vie aujourd'hui il est important de
continuer à accélérer le rythme de la
vaccination sinon il sera impossible de
faire face à la propagation de
l'infection en outre il est nécessaire
de maintenir au niveau approprié le
volume des tests dans les régions afin
de détecter les malades attendent de les
aider et de protéger des autres contre
l'infection à moscou aussi la situation
demeure inquiétante
ce que n'a pas manqué de souligner le
maire de la capitale
n'aurait jamais pensé la situation à
moscou reste donc de la semaine dernière
le nombre de cas diagnostiqués a
augmenté de 14 % et le nombre
d'hospitalisations de 10% ce suivi
évidemment la hausse se poursuit
peut-être pas avec une telle dynamique
mais l'augmentation est sérieuse le
nombre d'hospitalisations par rapport
aux cas de maladie diagnostiquée est
inférieur à celui des périodes
précédentes
nij
pourquoi parce qu'en fin de compte
commencer grand nombre de personnes ont
été vaccinées et cela bien sûr au dessus
sur la gravité de la maladie le nombre
d'hospitalisations le nombre de
personnes en soins intensifs
près d'un tiers de la population russe
est actuellement reçu les deux doses du
vaccin pour inciter les habitants à se
faire vacciner la majorité des régions
adopter de nouvelles restrictions ou
s'apprêtent à le faire notamment en
introduisant un système de pass
sanitaires dans les restaurants et les
cafés une semaine chômée sera par
ailleurs mis en place au niveau national
du 30 octobre au 7 novembre pendant
cette période a moscou les restaurants
salles de sport centres commerciaux et
cinéma seront fermés d'après dmitri
peskov porte-parole du kremlin si ces
mesures pourraient être prolongés au
pain de confinement total nous toutefois
prévus dans la capitale